gráfica fx igual a logaritmo natural de
2x y bueno para hacer la gráfica de esta
función lo que voy a hacer es tomarme
una tabla con valores de x y de la
función sin embargo para ello tomarme
los valores de fx y de x lo que voy a
usar es la calculadora y esto es
bastante irónico porque la calculadora
es gráfica dora y aunque se podría hacer
la gráfica con esta calculadora gráfica
dora voy a construir la gráfica a mano
así que voy a hacer una tabla y aquí voy
a poner a x y aquí
efe de x y bueno antes de hacer mi
sustitución de los valores de xy de
igual a fx que ojo y es muy variable
dependiente por lo tanto lo voy a poner
en el eje de las variables dependientes
antes de empezar a poner valores por
aquí
lo que quiero es fijarme en el dominio
de esta función y es que tengo el
logaritmo natural de 2 x cuál es el
dominio de una función logaritmo natural
y bueno recuerda que la función
logaritmo natural es exactamente lo
mismo que tomarme el logaritmo en base y
todo el logaritmo está definido para los
números más grandes
es decir para los números positivos
porque porque aunque yo me pueda tomar
una potencia a la cual le leve que sea
muy pero muy negativa esto se va a
acercar bastante a cero sin embargo
nunca va a tocar el cero y más aún no
hay ninguna potencia a la cual yo pueda
elevar el número que me dé un número
negativo por lo tanto 2x es decir lo que
está dentro del lugar istmo tiene que
ser mayor que cero y si divido ambos
lados de la ecuación entre 2 me da que x
tiene que ser mayor que 0 este es mi
dominio de mi función nuestro dominio
van a ser todos los números reales que
sean mayores que 0 y bueno ahora qué
pasaría si nos acercamos al cero es
decir voy a empezar con valores de x muy
cercanos al cero para ver qué es lo que
ocurre supongamos que me tomo no sé el
0.1 el 0.5 y después me voy al 1 y
después me voy al
se me ocurre el 5 pero creo que la
escalas no me daría para tanto creo que
mejor a algo más cercano para que veas
qué es lo que está pasando creo que
suena bien 1.5 y después irme hasta el 3
para no hacer la escala tan grande
entonces no voy a tomar estos valores de
equis y pues vamos a ver cuánto valen
los valores de bien pero antes déjenme
hacer mis ejes coordinados por aquí este
es mi eje de las x de mi variable
independiente mientras que el otro es mi
eje de las 10 es decir de mi variable
dependiente este es mi jersey es estas
medidas x y xv hasta 3 entonces
supongamos que este es uno estos dos y
hasta acá va a estar el 3 y por lo tanto
aquí está punto 5 1.5 y 2.5 y bueno
ahora sí ya tengo una escala que me
parece agradable creo que es hora de
sacar la calculadora la t 85 así que
empecemos a trabajar con ella y lo
primero que quiero hacer es el logaritmo
natural y ojo no olvides que es 2x
entonces me queda 2 x punto 1 en lo cual
es el logaritmo
punto 2 10 - 1.609 menos 1.61 menos 1.6
1 y ha redondeado menos 1.6 1 y después
tengo el lugar y no natural de dos veces
cero puntos y encuestas lo podremos ser
en la mente el logaritmo natural de
bueno lo voy a apuntar para que veas de
dónde sale cada una de las cosas sin
embargo pues esto lo podremos hacer
hasta mental 2 por punto sin con lo cual
d es el logaritmo natural de 1 y bueno
pues logaritmo natural de 1 a qué
potencia tengo que elevar cualquier base
para que me dé 1 pues la respuesta es 0
y ahí está pero te das cuenta esto sólo
podríamos ser mental peruano está bien
que lo comprobemos con la calculadora
ahora me tengo que tomar el 1 el
logaritmo natural de dos veces 1
logaritmo natural de 2 veces uno lo cual
es 2 2 por 1 y bueno esto va a ser igual
a cuánto esto va a ser igual am
0.6 93 y esto tiene toda la lógica del
mundo porque 2 x 1 es menor que el valor
de recuerda que el número es
aproximadamente 2.7 18 por lo tanto 2 es
menor que 2.718 y por lo tanto el
logaritmo natural de todos tiene que ser
menor que 1 es decir 0.69 ahora vamos a
tomarnos el lugar y no natural de 2 x
1.5 en lo cual desde el lugar y más
durante 3 y esto ahora sí va a ser más
grande que 11.098 1.1 vamos a redondear
lo 1.1 1.10 y después tengo el lugar y
natural de 3 por 2 el lugar y natural de
dos veces 32 por 36 y bueno cuando me
tomo el logaritmo natural de 6 esto me
va a dar de respuesta a 1.79 1
1.79 1 esto lo podemos escribir déjenme
cambiar de color
cómo 1.79 muy bien ya que tengo estos
valores date cuenta que mi valor más
pequeño es menos 1.61 mientras que mi
valor más grande es 1.79 y eso me sirve
para dar una escala aquí en mi eje de
las 10 en mi variable dependiente
entonces voy a decir que este es menos
uno por aquí está en menos dos y para
arriba tengo que caminar más sobre las
cosas iguales déjenme hacer más grande
este eje este es el eje de asx esta es
mi eje de las guías que por cierto y es
igual a de fx y entonces por aquí tengo
al 1 por aquí tengo al 2 y pues vamos a
poner aquí también el menos punto 5 el
menos 1.5 el punto 5 y el 1.5 y ahora sí
llegó el momento de graficar los puntos
y el primer punto es x igual a 0.1 y
igual a menos 1.6 uno más o menos por
aquí de hecho es un poco más pegado al
eje de las 10 algo como x
y justo aquí tengo a mi primer punto que
es el punto cero punto 1 - 1.61 muy bien
este punto está representado por estos
dos de aquí después tengo si x vale 0.5
vale 0 entonces si x vale 0.5 lleva de 0
estamos justo aquí déjame ponerlo x vall
de 0.5 vale 0 y ya tengo este punto de
azul y ahora vámonos a nuestra tercera
coordenada cuando x vale 1 llévale 0.69
cuando x vale 1 llévale 0.69 que estamos
justo por aquí bueno de hecho creo que
estamos más pegados a punto 5 que a 1
entonces mejor es que me ponerle un
poquito más abajo para que sea más
realista recuerda que todo esto es un
aproximado como lo estamos haciendo a
mano no lo tomes como dogma de fe aquí
tenemos un 0.69 nuestro tercer punto y
vámonos al cuarto el cuarto es x igual a
1.5 y 1.10
x igual a 1.5 y igual a 1.10 estamos
como por aquí aproximadamente y vamos a
escribirlo cuando x vale 1.5 no
aumentamos mucho llévale 1.10 y creo que
ya estás viendo para dónde va esta
gráfica y estás viendo el patrón de esta
gráfica pero vamos a graficar el último
punto y dice cuando x vale 3 llévale
1.79 estamos más o menos por aquí un
poquito más pegado al 2 eso más o menos
este punto 3 1.79 muy bien y ya que
tenemos todos estos puntos pues vamos a
unirlos de color blanco para hacer
nuestra gráfica así que vamos a empezar
como por aquí este es el cero y vamos a
unir todos estos puntos y date cuenta
que cada vez que nos acercamos más al
eje de las 10 entonces tomamos valores
más negativos en 10 es decir cada vez
que nos acercamos más a x igual a 0
tomamos valores más negativos y después
vamos subiendo vamos subiendo por acá
vamos subiendo más por acá y aquí está
la gráfica de mi función y es igual al
lugar
de 2x y date cuenta de que quiere algo
muy importante cada vez que nos
acercamos al cero
tomamos valores más negativos pero ojo
no podemos tocar el cero nunca porque
aunque tomemos un valor muy pero muy
pero muy negativo vamos a estar muy pero
muy pero muy cerca del cero pero nunca
vamos a hacer cero y es que fíjate bien
si nos tomamos elevado a la menos unos
1000 millones esto es igual en primer
lugar a algo muy cercano a cero es decir
no estamos tomando 1 / elevado a la mil
millones lo que si te das cuenta es un
número muy pero muy pero muy pero muy
pequeño y estamos por lo tanto es muy
pero muy pero muy pegados a cero sin
embargo nunca tocamos el cero esta es
una de las propiedades importantes de
los logaritmos y ya está ya tenemos la
gráfica del logaritmo natural de 2x que
por cierto quiero que observes que
tienen la misma forma que todas las
gráficas de los logaritmos